früher wurden unter der linde der
gemeinde lin gerichts urteile verkündet
verliebte tauschen heute hier küsse aus
und in der zukunft voitsberg einer der
favorisierten standorte tief unter der
erde wird vielleicht eins der
helvetische atommüll gelagert
der techniker thomas griplevel in linn
über die definitiven lagerung von hoch
radioaktivem abfall sprechen
genau an diesem ort weil ihr die zeit
greifbar scheint
die linde soll 800 jährige sein
800 jahre ist das viel ein endlager
müsste 150 tausend jahre überdauern
weltweit lagern in akw s und zwischen
deponien 350.000 tonnen hochradioaktiver
müll
jedes jahr kommen 12.000 tonnen dazu die
tödlichen restbestände symbolisieren die
grenzen der technik und des menschlichen
denkens
er verweist auf den technik philosophen
günther anders vorstellungsvermögen
überstieg das ihr heutiges nimmer
vorstellen und auch emotional empfinden
was mir darauf der ethiker engagiert
sich in einer bewegung die das atomare
risiko als unkalkulierbar einschätzt die
erde bietet kein stabiles fundament sei
in bewegung konstatiert er und warnt vor
geologischen verwerfungen
das ist für mich
wie komplex und spekulativ die
modellrechnungen für eine endlagerung
sind zeigt der dokumentarfilm into
eternity
auf einer finnischen insel entsteht das
endlager um kalow 100.000 jahre projekt
tief im erdinneren
der engpass
die lagerstätte wird geschlossen und
verfüllt der grundgedanke der verfüllung
ist die rückkehr zu weitgehend den
bedingungen die vor dem tunnelbau
bestanden haben sollen unsere nachfahren
vor diesem ort gewarnt werden wie
kennzeichnend man so etwas dauerhaft
oder ist es sicherer wenn die menschheit
um kalow ganz vergisst 45 jahre dauert
die suche nach einem endlager in der
schweiz ringen um eine lösung die
sicherheit verspricht nicht nur für
kommende generationen sondern für eine
halbe ewigkeit kann aus einer solchen
odyssee des scheiterns je eine
geschichte des gelingens werden wo im
begriff in endlage drinsteckt
prinzip hoffnung also hoffen dass die
technik dieser abfälle irgendwann
unschädlich machen kann und wenn nicht
laut einer sage geht die welt unter wenn
der schatten der linde nicht jedes jahr
einmal auf das nahe gelegene schloss
fällt bisher hat es immer geklappt